bonjour bonsoir oui on a tous nos
manières d'habitude on a des histoires
comme bâle qui ne sont arrivés et
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler des
miennes qui ne sont pas des moindres à
naître avec db j'ai la phobie de la
caresse uk alors qu'est ce que la phobie
la caresse du pied déjà quand je suis
allongée tout temps peur qu'un objet via
de déflorer la paume des pieds ou que
quelqu'un bm vient de faire des guilis
oui c'est totalement ridicule je sais
alors j'ai plusieurs réactions face à ça
très souvent chargé qu'une petite fille
de 8 ans et je j'adopte là la position
politique commune ouest a fait autant
des fois je viens plutôt violent oui
[Musique]
j'adore éviter les blondes in sa cuisse
et je fais absolument tous les jours se
vouer en situations qu'il a absolument
aucun rapport avec les pouvant tout lors
m
bon ce sommet
jean paul bachy tiens
quand je suis fatigué et un appel pour
centrer génétique et autant vous dire
que ces tics me font chier
voilà je me bats pour un conte des trois
prochains jours ah non non je suis
content je génétique elle en fait bon
manger non j'ai eu 22 points de suture
et moi parce que je suis un énorme orage
squeeze il ya sept ans l'époque où il
n'avait qu'à ce lundi pour lui son frère
aventure oui je n'ai plus jamais retaper
dans un cadre de toute ma vie après ça
alors comme vous pouvez pas je me suis
cassé les deux dents de devant à la plus
pleine jungle jeunes
c'était en ce2 et autant que j'appelais
cette histoire est complètement ridicule
je me demande actuellement qu'est ce que
le mec qui a eu cette idée avait dans la
tête
ce qu'il avait un gros problème à ma
psychologie on s'arrête pas je me suis
fait percer le rideau champs ci-haut de
temps vous dire que quand je suis allé à
l'école pour la première fois après
m'être fait percer j'étais un peu le
quine de l'école primaire
par contre une semaine d'après et
troisième ex souffre et perd c'est leur
ego chaussée ce qui fait que c'était
devenu totalement banale 1 et que je
n'avais plus aucune reconnaissance de la
part du moins qu'on peut dire individus
de cette école
salut je vais couper la tête je mettrais
sa tête voire brique et le béton au
milieu de la cour pour que tout le monde
se souvient mon autorité je sais pas si
c'est parce que j'ai regardé de films
d'horreur alors que j'avais en dessous
de l'âge autorisé délinquants mais j'ai
la phobie diouf je t'attrape le pied
c'est bien de dégainer pas d'un lit
alors plus haut niveau d'un jour où
d'une fente j'ai peur humain me la
trappe
voilà
[Musique]
celui là je pratique aussi le test de
l'haleine ce qui fait que quand elle
voit une fille qui m'intéresse je sens
pour nallet voilà l'hiver ça me met
peut-être un peu trop en confiance sur
ton haleine ouais ouais c'est beau
c'était mylène et serait dû marcher
normalement
[Musique]
oh